Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and Orphan Black
is back!
I didn’t catch season 1 till after it finished
airing, but I’ll be doing weekly videos
for Season 2.
This will be my first one, but in case any
of you aren’t up to speed on what’s going
on I’ll do a super quick recap before my
Top 5 moments.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do a ton of BBC show videos like Doctor
Who, Sherlock and Orphan Black.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
So super quick recap of CloneClub season 1.
We introduced to the Dyad Clone conflict via
Sarah, and even though the perspective shifts
based on which Clone is in a scene I always
thought of her as being the main protagonist.
Rachel and Doctor Leekie are essentially the
main villains until we find out about Helena
who becomes kind of the second big villain
but that only really comes out near the end
of the season.
The Dyad is essentially trying to advance
human genetics and make it so that they can
own human DNA, clone DNA really, but eventually
it’s implied that big Pharmaceutical companies
will start owning people like you would own
possessions.
Really bad for everyone.
Because all the clones were like a beta trial
for all their human experimentation and they’re
starting to break down a la Katja, the Dyad
corrals them as part of their ongoing research
and Helena, with the aide of the original
cloning scientists starts to hunt down and
eliminate them.
So think of the Dyad villains as an allegory
for big pharma treating pushing the idea of
self-directed evolution through science.
And Helena as like the religous zealot who’s
completely opposed to the idea of self directed
evolution.
The clones are the collateral damage and band
together to survive.
So now that we’re caught up I’m going
to do my Top 5 moments from the episode and
then my review.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet.
Here we go, Number 5 - Alison goes Shopping.
I love Alison so much, I have a feeling she’s
going to be my favorite Clone this season.
The shopping scene was hilarious and in case
you missed it, every time there was an Alison
scene after this they used the same funny
music cues.
Like the music would go from really serious
to light and funny.
Meaning, that all of the comedy in the episode
and maybe the season would be flowing from
Alison.
You get this real sense that Alison is a reluctant
participant.
She’s the only one with a traditional home
situation.
So even when she skyped in for a Clone meeting
later you could see her ironing her family's
laundry in the background.
And then we have to talk about her play.
Number 4 - Alison’s Play
The play itself is a really funny meta story
about Alison’s role in the fight against
Dyad as well as a callback to season 1 a la
cleaning up unfortunate bodies..
I love how they called back to Felix’s Cats
comment about the name of the play.
Who else listened to the actual lyrics they
were singing.
It was all about plasma leaking on the floor
and cleaning up blood.
Which kind of harks back to Cosima and Delphine
with the blood samples.
As much as I think this is all Sarah’s story
and the other clones are just in it.
That’s really not true.
Orphan Black is the overstory all the clones’
stories, so everytime we jump to a scene with
a different clone, there’s always references
to what’s happening with the other clones.
Like Alison’s play references Cosima’s
blood and Sarah cleaning up Katja’s body.
It gets a bit confusing trying to use every
scene to call back to moments from all the
clones, so high fives to the writers for keeping
the narrative so complex and interesting.
Number 3 - Sara Tricks Daniel with Alison
This was one of the funniest attempted abductions
ever.
It was hard to tell if Alison actually knew
it was going to happen because it seemed like
she was surprised.
She was skyping in while Sarah was planning
how to get into the Dyad, but I think they
just cut Alison out of the conversation when
they were setting her up as a distraction
to get Daniel away.
Side note, I also feel like this was a good
anti-kidnapping PSA, even though they did
get her in the van eventually.
So in case anyone ever tries to abduct you,
blow your rape whistle AND pepper spray the
shit of of anything in your field of vision.
Even though Daniel let her go, they totally
deserved to get maced.
Alison said that she wasn’t keeping guns
at home anymore, but I was surprised she didn’t
have one on her.
I love how she just accepted Daniel’s apology
and slid out of the Van, like thanks a lot
asshole bye!
Number 2 - Doctor Leekies Speech
There was a lot going on at the Dyad party,
but it was Leekie’s speech that really interested
me.
He basically speechify’s the history of
the Dyad and how far their organization reaches
around the world.
Started in 1918 and now it’s got labs in
over a 100 countries with over 27,000 employees.
It’s the personification of big pharma.
Remember his mission, which is tied up in
the philosophy of Neolutionism, is self-directed
evolution.
That’s why the clones exist and why they
called Kira a biological goldmine.
Leekie believes she’s the next stage of
evolution.
The clones on the other hand are breaking
down slowly.
In case you missed it, they made their plan
of owning human DNA a lot clearer during Rachel’s
meeting with the Koreans.
and my Number 1 moment - Helena is still alive.
This was like the major WTF of the episode.
Sarah and Art put the pieces together after
he explains what was going on with the Diner
attack.
I liked that they called them religous zealots.
They looked creepy when I just thought they
were working for Rachel.
Who buttons that top button without wearing
anything around their neck.
Matt Smith’s Doctor would be rolling in
his grave.
Helena’s plan seems pretty simple, just
kill all the clones.
Right now I don’t think she has any grand
design.
She literally just wants them all dead.
I don’t think she intends to hurt Kira,
but she might kill Mrs S.
I actually checked the Orphan Black hashtag
on Twitter right as the episode was ending
and it was just an endless stream of HELENAs
in all caps.
Let me know what your favorite moment was,
Alison’s Play, the Helena reveal or something
else?
And let me know who your favorite clone was
this week.
Here’s a couple more really important moments
that weren’t my favorite, but that we need
to talk about in the comments.
Cosima and Delphine, who is playing who the
best?
Cosima is definitely on team Clone Club, but
there’s this spy versus spy thing going
on with Delphine working with Leekie to get
Cosima on their side.
I think underneath it all Delphine isn’t
as geniuine as say Art, who’s trying to
get Sarah to trust him.
Delphine didn’t realize she was kissing
Sarah till after their whole run in with Leekie.
You’d think that if you were in love with
someone and had been in a relationship, you’d
know if the person you were kissing was someone
else.
Plus Sarah’s hair wasn’t even the same.
Maybe Delphine is just the worst girlfriend
ever?
As for Art I think he’ll be a force for
good.
Even if he’s technically not on Team Clone
Club.
The same goes for Paul.
He’s playing both sides, but I think he
really cares about Sarah.
I don’t think any of those double agent
relationships will end well, Delphine or Paul.
Overall though I gave the episode an A minus,
it was a great entry to season 2.
Especially considering that the hardest job
the show has is topping itself.
Season 1 was so good it’s going to be hard
to keep one-upping the stakes.
Enter Helena.
I think part of the solution and the episode
explained it beautifully, is to go international.
Season 1 was fairly self contained geographically.
Remember how Rachel was asking Paul all those
questions about speaking Mandarin and going
to Taiwan.
That also ties back into Leekie’s speech
about Dyad having offices all over the world.
The story of season 2 is just going to be
told from a much more global context.
The only thing I thought could have be done
better was Felix’s story in the episode.
He, just like Alison was just a well of comedy
they used to drive the plot forward.
But Alison’s scenes were all so complex
and interesting, they kind of made Felix seem
like the throwaway character this week.
The fool essentially.
Although I kind of think of his archetype
as the fool.
Not in a bad way though.
I kind of go into hyper aware mode whenever
the clones are all together in a scene.
I kind of think of them as different aspects
of the freudian psyche.
Like one clone is the id, one is the ego and
one is the superego.
I guess you could also divide them into the
subconscious and conscious.
But let me know if you agree.
Like when they’re all together, they’re
like a whole person, they’re all pieces
of a single person.
Like I said, I’m going to be doing weekly
videos for episodes every Saturday night.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Tomorrow is Game of Thrones episode 3, so
to start getting ready for that, here’s
my video for last week’s episode and here’s
my latest Doctor Who series 8 video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!